starting off uh this hour though is uh
my pro football
hall of fame friend um joining us
by uh by way of our uh his his company
defy
which we always like to talk about when
he calls in uh number 30 in your program
number one in your heart and i'm not
talking about philip lindsay
talking about terrell davis how are you
teddy what's going on man good morning
how's life
life is good life's good i can't
complain i can't kids
kids online learning kids online
learning in the david's house
they start up uh what's today they start
tuesday they start next tuesday
so they get everything wrapped up and
we'll be back at home being teachers and
parents and counselors
okay yep uh you know and judges and uh
you know itself how's the ipad time in
the house how's that working td
oh you know
all rules have been thrown out man all
the rules have been thrown out like
it's been ridiculous you know we had
this this rule about you know an hour a
day of please i mean it went from an
hour a day to like you know what
man just take it because
i just
hey it's either that or it's like you
have a choice man to keep your sanity
right
yes keep your sanity or you just got to
tap
out and so um the fight just you know
we fought a good fight
so in a second are you saying your kids
again are i think we have the kids of
the same age
although yours might be a little younger
so how old are how old are your kids
yeah 975. okay so basically in terms of
uh ipad time and your rules of screen
time in the
in the davis household you and your
lovely wife decided to
you you got around you stuck in there
right around midfield
um and then you just started running the
ball and punted that's basically what
you did three and out
right around midfield you're right you
stalled out you stalled out and you
punted
we would put on third down sometimes
oh man all right td let's talk a little
bit of ball um
i am high on your broncos man i'm very
high on them
i aren't mad no i'm serious i'm not just
saying that for you
uh because you're here and i know what
it but i
i kind of dig the way drew glock
finished i like it
i like the addition of melvin gordon um
that jerry judy dropped
to them and they just jumped on it for a
good reason jumped on that kid from
alabama
i like the the receivers the way they
were coming along uh if i'm not mistaken
a particular wolverine at tight end is
finally healthy
in jake booty who is was dynamite
so you got little hey don't let it don't
laugh man
yeah he is gonna throw it out there uh
defensively i think fangio's got them uh
all buying in year two what are you am i
am i on to something here or am i
uh i like i i like your analysis man i
like your observations
yeah i think there's there's a lot of
excitement in denver you know talking
people there
and you talked about it just to see a
quarterback that they've uh
they really feel like this is the one
you know this for many years since
i guess peyton manning uh you know
denver has been trying to find that
signal caller trying to find that the
guy who
occupies the most important position in
in the sport and
uh it's been a turn style since and so
uh what we saw last year
with uh you know drew lock coming in in
the last five games and he went 401 down
the stretch
and just really um got people excited
you know not only from just the
standpoint of you know going 4-1 but
you know this just the i guess the swag
that he has
the the kind of uh you know football
football iq i mean a man in missouri
he had like a different coordinator
every year so
he's got a real good football iq um
guys love him they like being around him
he's got that uh
you know infectious personality he's got
he's got that it factor you know when he
when he comes on the field you feel like
you got a chance to win and that's
that's
that's important for a quarterback to
have that so
yeah i mean so that's one and then you
talked about the weapons they they
surrounded him and surrounded him with
you know cortland
sutton was already there but you bring
in a jerry judea kj
hamler and you know you get alvaro and
he's still got noah fan and your boy
jake
booty as you call him from missouri i
mean from uh michigan and the beacon uh
i mean obviously you stay healthy i
think that's that's the key there
and then freeman and you know you
obviously you got lindsay and
uh they got fat too who suddenly
you know uh was dynamic when drew locke
started
started you know what i mean like that
yeah that's
so so um are they are they my sleeper
team for 2020 because that's where i've
been leaning
td they they they could be man i might
be listening
and i'm not speaking from the homeworks
position here i i think legitimately
when you talk about the defense where
they got the rotation from tennessee and
you know he's got a point a point to
prove uh shelby harris they resigned him
and
you know you you got von miller and i
remember this whole
or last year you know bradley chubb
missed significant time he wasn't even
there
uh this is the second year in this
system and you hear that from a lot of
players they talk about
how complex this fangio's defense is and
so to be able to go through it for a
second time now i don't even have the
off season or
you know regular mini camps and otas but
still just to be in that system for a
second time i think these guys are going
to be
uh be great i mean and then bryce
calling on even play last year he
uh you know he came over with uh with
big handgeo and green jackson man we're
the best
you know we got probably one of the best
safety fandoms in the game and i say
weak
uh but karine jackson and justin zimmer
so you know aj booyah i just think from
all the things that i'm saying the
pieces that are in place the confidence
of this young team
yes i think they can definitely be a
sleeper team and uh
i'm i'm picking them to uh i mean kansas
city is gonna be harder than knockoff
i was about to say i was about to say
unfortunately
um yeah kansas city appears to be able
to make a run it's difficult to say that
the
the one that the patriots just had
because you talked about 20 years of a
coaching quarterback hooked at the
at the hip um and the afc west i think
is much
tougher and will have a lot more
continuity within it than the
afc east did in the 20 years of the
brady belichick rule but
it sure looks like the chiefs are set up
for a nice long run here
td you know yeah yeah i mean you just
look at it i mean that their
foundational pieces are
are pretty young i mean kelsey's and
it's like an eighth year i believe but
um other than that you have a young
quarterback that's already improving
it's already achieved and accomplished
so much in his young career the weapons
that they have around him
it's just like one of those things where
you say what could derail this team
and typically uh i'd say a few things
one is if they had a rash of injuries
that's the one thing we could never
project or predict having injuries
um i think the second thing would be if
they were to start
looking back at 2019 and it's always
about okay when we take the field we're
going to win
and you know because we've always won
and that you have to stay in the now
they can get their minds into the now
and plan 2020 as if
they didn't win a championship they have
to maintain that hunger
you know and or you might you might have
a team
uh that just matches up with them
remember i don't know if you remember
early in the season
last year where they played detroit and
then they played indy
and they couldn't beat man coverage and
they struggled a little bit during
during
that little stretch during the season
everybody thought well the way you beat
kansas cities you have to
you know defend them with man coverage
well they figured it out
but um unlike basketball baseball
in the postseason it's a one game series
so if somebody gives you problems in the
problems in a one game series you don't
have time to
you know make those corrections and then
come back next week and try to
you know correct it so that's that's
what makes football challenging me to
repeat it's just once you hit the
postseason there is no series that's one
game and that's
if you don't bring your best that one
game you can go home terrell davis
joining me here
on the rich eisen show how impactful is
the fournette signing in tampa
just wow man that's that's ridiculous
it looks like it it's starting to look
like a um
like a pro bowl roster like it's looking
ridiculous like wait a minute
how are they uh how are they getting all
these players they've already had
most of them but they bring me in lesean
mccoy you now get leonard fournette
and you get tom brady on your squad and
uh you know now uh
it's still we've seen before where you
have these rosters and i believe one
time
uh if i'm not mistaken it was
quarterback who said that
man we have this uh uh who is that
um vince young is the quarterback for
the philadelphia eagles
declared their team to have like this um
you know this roster and it was a good
roster at the time
but we know in football it really is
about chemistry right it's about
all these pieces working together and
then you gotta
you have to make sure you keep people
happy everybody has to know their role
and and
the question would be once they start to
go through the season whether it has
success or not
are these players happy with their role
and
only time would tell but you know if
you're you know
mike evans he's used to getting the ball
a lot if you're
chris got him when you're used to
getting the ball a lot well if that
changes how would that affect them
oh you're trying to you're trying to sow
some doubt here i think tv 12 and bruce
arians will handle that
yeah i i just don't see no look you
would know
obviously better than i would about how
right now right right now is this team
the box right now your super bowl
favorite like you you you
you put them in people
td it's going to be tough not to i'm
going to be honest with you man
it's it's gonna be tough not to to just
jump
head first i don't see an nfc east team
being better i don't i mean in their own
division though
i i get it no i know i know the falcons
who look like they are going to be
like they're not going to stand quietly
say oh we're going to take
no they're going to take uh yeah they're
not going to just bow to them to the box
i know but i i totally understand your
2011 eagles dream team analogy
i totally understand that when you amass
when you um well
they were coming off a lockout i
remember that that's when vince young
said dream team yeah we're back and
dream team
is like hold on a minute uh but we're
not talking about
you know vince young isn't the tb's tb12
isn't the vince young
quarterback that got acquired and you
know uh
gronk isn't the namdi awesome one you
know what i mean like this is
this is significant um in terms of the
additional talent and i think aryans is
gonna
he knows i mean he's been there he's
done that i i just
it's tough not to think and just jump
headfirst and go all in on this thing
right now yeah yeah i mean i'm not i'm
not
biting you on it um it sounds like your
i'll be honest with you it sounds like
it look literally here
td just treat me like i want a third
hour of an ipad and just move on
terrell davis here on the rich eisen
show how's your business going what's
going on with your business
you're yeah it's doing well man we've
been uh my company's defy a co-founder
defy and uh you know
go to drinkdefy.com and you know we've
been at it for over
two three years now um so yeah we're
still
we're still moving man we've uh we
launched our the five zero months ago
which is pretty awesome but
for those of you who don't know what it
is it's a performance drink uh that's
the cbd and it
has no thc electrolytes uh
coconut water and b vitamins all the
good things you need to allow you to be
able to perform
you know maintain and recover so you
don't have to be an athlete to do it you
can be somebody's weekend warrior who
just wants to feel better
but it certainly has helped help me out
a lot um and i'm constantly
uh using our products we also have a
tincture which is the oil and we have a
muscle bomb so
we just rich my my my love is just to be
able to help somebody feel better and to
uh
to be active in their lives and be able
to work out without pain
and uh and swelling and be able to be
the best that they can be and so
uh with saying that we have products uh
that can help you
um you know obtain those goals so please
visit us at again drinkdefy.com and uh
it's been it's been good man how you
like business how do you like being a
ceo
how do you like that a co-founder i like
it
it's good it's uh like you man you're
the ceo look at you running your own
show man so it's like that you know that
that
you know that uh that feeling you get
every morning when you wake up and
you go off to uh and it's not even work
it's like you
you go off to uh i mean number one i
don't go into an
office or anything well no i don't think
anybody really does anymore these days
unfortunately right even when we were
going to the offices i wasn't
i wasn't going into an office oh okay
wow
look at you i was ahead
i was already ahead of this man i
already seen this coming you saw i see
okay i already seen the home home uh
well it's all hands on deck we
established that to begin uh this
conversation it's all hands on deck in
your household right now
oh my god so what's your super bowl pick
who's yours yeah i haven't i haven't
picked one yet i know you did the thing
for the network they sent out the uh
i know players of the year yeah i know i
got that too terrell davis you know what
i did i
i just fired it right back i came up
with my answers and i fired it right
back
oh yes okay so who
but here's what i would say i'm leaning
toward these two teams being in
the in the big dance okay and it's new
orleans
and kansas city those are the two
that i'm i'm i'm feeling good
last year i had minnesota playing the
chiefs in the super bowl of course
vikings didn't live up to their part but
uh chiefs did and uh
i i just i don't think kansas city is
just going to be too hard
that's when we talk afc and yep right
here's the saints i think the same to do
why breezes last dance yeah i think i
think
this is the last dance for drew brees i
think this is it my man has never
gotten the um you know player of the
year award or
mvp i think this is the year he gets
that he uh he finally walks away with
another ring and uh
you know the things just look like you
know defensively they're
they're pretty good up front and uh they
can
they balance well with that offense and
don't you know that offense is 30
something points don't
probably be number one or two squad
offense
um yeah i just i don't know it's one of
those gut feelings that and
listen nobody knows anything at this
point we haven't seen anybody that's
right
i know crazy i know so i hear you but
yeah but you know what i'm gonna stay
with that that's gonna be my take for
the rest of
you guys you guys changed on the show
everybody we
actually were allowed excuse me we're a
lot of mulligan on our thanksgiving show
on our thanksgiving show we're allowed
mulligans
and last year i didn't take it last year
i didn't take it i stuck with my
preseason
pick of uh i i took uh patriots versus
um uh no actually i stuck with ravens
versus um
no i changed you're right
i thought you had san francisco how dare
you how dare you make me uh
change uh you know try and remember
something a year ago it feels like a
decade ago
you know it feels like a decade ago no i
know
my point is this right listen we're
talking about super bowl
in the in the beginning of september and
even even we were talking about this
in like july it's like all right it made
some sense when you can see a team
practice you can kind of see them go
through preseason games
i mean even then it doesn't make a lot
of sense but you know what for
entertainment values i'll i'll give you
a team
but i'm gonna stick with mine i'm not
changing i'm going kc in new orleans
all right there it is right there yeah
write that down okay
write it down casey in new orleans very
very very
thick limb that uh terrell davis went
out on right there
number one and number three betting
favorites
great job terrell wow
let's just say he only he only puts the
defy in his uh in his uh business
let's just put it that way all right all
right do you take care of yourself
all right guys thanks a lot that's it
tyrell underscore davis on twitter at
the real terrell davis on instagram love
that guy hey you watched all the way to
the end
thanks for that watch more right here